so for all all of you who have done
really really cool stuff in your career
if someone has never seen anything
you've done before what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
and you cannot say
Argy Henry you
start um I'm G to try and keep it
somewhat in the family it's an old
colleague of Matthews Man from Uncle I
think would be go
mine would be Black Mirror probably all
right yeah what's the
question job that you did that what you
want to be a so what is it okay but not
our go what job are you most proud of I
think is
Imagine or or it could just be something
you want people more people to watch oh
did you say uh there's a film coming out
called stunt man that that is pretty
exciting film I think it's going to be
amazing it's
amazing the future that's a bad idea
yeah I meant from the past don't rest on
your laurels yeah
exactly rest on your future from the
past and what from the past Sam past uh
snow angels I just pulled that out of my
butt it's not the first time he said
that yeah hi I got nothing no I guess um
what do you got I got you we all have
waiting for Gman how about be okay
waiting for Gman oh yeah waiting for
Gman um thank you Sam I would probably
have to say Kingsman because right yeah
yeah it was the first time I felt like I
could actually direct a film so that was
the first time I felt like I become a
director last curveball before we get to
Ary what is for each of you what is the
most nervous you've been before the
first night of filming uh and
why well for me it was layer cake
because I really had never even looked
through a a camera and uh so that was my
first time trying to trying to direct a
film so that was pretty ner rcking and
lockstock as well that was the first
time I tried to produce a film and then
I realized that none of us on the crew
director oh me had ever made a movie
before and uh it was the most fun I've
ever had learning to make a film while
making a
film I'm going to say waiting for
guffman again because it was the first
of four improvised movies that I did
with Chris guest and Eugene Levy and the
night before waiting for guffman I knew
all the dialogue was going to be
improvised but I just didn't know how it
was going to work and Chris said just
don't I'm just telling people don't try
to be funny but then you just show up on
set everybody's got their characters and
then you feed off of each other and lift
each other up and but yeah that was
scary aming good scary it's good to be
scared isn't it yeah it's good to be
scared definitely yeah I I'd say box of
moonlight is a movie I did with John T
years ago oh thanks uh yes that I was
pretty scary on that I was pretty scary
on that but that fear is an interesting
thing isn't it I mean it comes out of
nowhere on a film anxiety what have you
it it's so Random sometimes you might
have prepared and done your work or not
and and then it just comes out of
nowhere sometimes I find be
random um so for me it was it was very
very specific it was that uh shooting
the last Jurassic we were uh the first
movie to come back during the pandemic
and I was shop foreman so I was the
contct with sag and responsible for the
actors and so um
coming back and shooting knowing you
know that this was very new terrain for
everyone and it was very important that
it worked um that was certainly the most
nervous that I've ever been uh and it
also happened to be a scene that was the
scene where I got like the most injured
it's when I was falling falling um out
of a out of a parachute I this happens
in movies for some reason that I'm in um
so sort of yeah ripped off a Band-Aid
with that one wow uh yeah I mean to
everyone else's point I think uh you can
get nervous and scared before most
scenes really it's good to have that
feeling it means the scene is alive
inside you but before I knew that uh was
the count of mon Christo which is my
first ever job and I was fresh out of
school and first ever professional job
and um I was terrified it was it was a
big movie and I just didn't know what to
expect and I didn't know if I was going
to be able to do it and uh yeah that was
a that was a pretty terrifying
experience well it must have been pretty
terrifying putting on this the
cape no yes Matthew that too
yeah yeah yeah yeah
Steve uh so this is for the cast you
guys have read a lot of scripts and I'm
curious what is it actually like reading
a script like this because it's so
unique with the way it does its twists
and turns and each Act is you know what
I mean it's so different than most
narrative
scripts almost as good as watching the
movie really it was a that I hate to you
know overuse a word but uh Paige Turner
really was like oh my God no what you
know yeah Jason fukes incredible
incredible writer producer on this film
um wrote Wonder Woman uh knows what he's
doing and and just it was one of those
kind of like Katherine was saying like
one of those unbelievable magical reads
where you're just like what this is so
good already and this is just meant to
be a template for the film and then it
was really wonderful to to get to see
you know Matthew's partnership with
Jason Jason has said to me that it's the
most inclusive experience that he's had
as a writer um and I think that the end
result is is is what it is you know in
large part because of that
partnership anyone
else could you remind me of the question
please I was just so enthralled by that
answer that the script what did you
think when you read it uh well it was
one of those scripts which you know as
you guys know lots of twists and turns
and you can almost see it in your mind's
eye Until you realize Matthew's in
charge and then you realize it's going
to be at least 12 times bigger than that
and so it was exciting it's one of those
things you think this is a special
moment this a special occasion this is a
something original some original Ip and
you know as as you guys all know I'm I'm
I don't necess necessarily do original
Ip that often um and it was an exciting
prospect especially when um you know
Matthew's in charge and you know you can
trust him I'm a huge fan of Matthew
Von's action set pieces uh I just there
yeah you should clap because they're
awesome so like so I'm curious
for the for the people that were invol
actually everyone was involved in a
little bit of action uh I'm just curious
what was it like on set filming with
Matthew with action and like for example
the train fight or the smoke dance or
oil I mean because they're all so
different than what you've seen in other
movies let's actually with the cast talk
a little bit about what it's like what I
said then Matthew I have a followup well
he ma Matthew wants something really
unique and that's why he hires the best
people around him and we mentioned the
the great Brad Allen who passed away
Damen Walters was his Protegé and he
shot a lot of second unit and um
directed second unit and then we had uh
and Brad was a prodige of Jackie Chan so
that's the the lineage of that stylized
violence in the film and Matthew wants a
sense of humor I think that that's
what's so unique about this the the
violence the stylized violence in his
films is that it's it's got humor and uh
that's what makes it
interesting can you guys talk a little
bit about what it's actually like to
film some of these sequences yeah yeah
challenging yeah it's challenging
because it's new techniques and I've
I've done a fair few fight scenes
throughout my career and walking into
this we knew it was going to be
something different and Matthew said
look everything we're doing is going to
be brand new and it may or may not work
so you're just going to have to work
really hard in the rehearsals and see
see what happens and then we'll try and
shoot that on on small cameras in
rehearsal and then come the day of
shooting everything may change it may or
may not work and and we pushed and push
and pushed and all that rehearsal time
and and all the work that Matthew puts
into pre-production pays off because Sam
and I on that train scene for example it
seemed to go Fairly seamlessly and it
was only because of the hard work put in
and so that makes a big difference you
go into a scene like that you do your
bit you do your hard work you do your
prep and everyone else has done it as
well and it turns out to be a really
fantastic scene and we filmed that in
the first two weeks which I think helped
we weren't physically exhausted so it
was um I I like to start sequen start
movies with a strong hard sequence
because it gets the crew up to speed
very quickly and um like the first thing
we shot in Kingson was the church
sequence and um it's just I think it's
you as um he liked improvising is a lot
of popping the cherry and um we got
through
it Matthew I'm so curious what you're
like um cuz you not only are you the
director but you're also the producer so
what is it like directing on set when
something isn't working does the
producer had ever come on and say you
know what I mean like what's that
balance for you I mean it really is
jacqulyn the Hyde um and it's pretty
intriguing that like from lir cake and
uh Stardust the producer of me was a lot
stronger than the director and um and
then I I think I wrote read Billy Wilder
quote that um um he he said to an
executive back in the day no one you
know the audience AR interested if you
came in on budget or on schedule doesn't
really affect you guys um so I've come a
little bit looser in that sense and so
the creative side is now 70% and the
producer 30% so I'm yeah I I I think I
wanted to tell as big a story as
possible and the producer me sort of
wimers in the background no but you you
make the impossible possible because you
you have a vision for something and then
and then typically you know a director
will and then the producer will say well
sorry that's cost prohibitive so let's
dream a little smaller and um and
because you don't you you can problem
solve your way through those obstacles
because you have that experience as a
producer and also because you're L you
know it's largely an independent film
for quite a while I think it's it's
really unique what you're able to do and
you strike a really powerful balance and
what I would say in terms of just
witnessing kind of Matthew just as a
leader on set and and what he's doing in
terms of in particular you know the
style of film making that is incredibly
Innovative um he is demanding and he
does not settle and it takes a lot of
courage to be that way because normally
we're all like oh are we going to get in
trouble if we go over if we don't do it
exactly how it was written and so
there's a constant discovery that worked
really well especially I think with you
I mean it was really exciting to see how
playful it could be and how things could
be discovered on such a giant movie and
it wasn't just like every day we have a
plan we're sticking to it because you
know this is way too expensive to begin
with you know so it was it was very
cool uh Matthew this is uh I don't think
the audience is going to think this
question's coming but the Taylor Swift
documentary actually played a part in
this movie
um yeah U well
well she didn't write the
book um I will say that now isn't that
what a spy would say yeah um yeah but
I'm not a
spy um in theory so no um yeah where my
my daughters watched um is it Miss
Americana um is that the name I heard
yeah yes and um I was sort of glancing
at it and then I saw the cat in a cat
pack and I was like what the hell is
that um and I what happens in my life is
I see things and if it grabs my
attention it goes into the we'll put
that in a movie and I'm not sure when or
where so I'm always just looking at life
and if I and and and you just see
something that's inspiring or funny or
powerful and you know that becomes that
will be in a scene sometime in the near
future
also what people don't realize is the
cat in this film originally was being
played by a professional until one day
when
Matthew oh you want sorry okay I was
like I was listening yeah carry on
that's really interesting I was just
giving a rate to
you yeah no basically after the first
day of filming um we had a professional
acting cat and
um you know what cats and acting aren't
exactly a um you know it's not true they
don't it's an anagram of acting cat I
just realized um but um but uh yeah so I
went to my daughter's bedroom and said
can I borrow your cat please and I took
the cat to work for three months and um
it was um yeah it was it was it was
actually at First a bit weird driving to
work with the cat looking after the cat
changing the cat's litter um being the
cat Handler as well as the Director but
um he became a very calming influence on
me and um
and I think I think he's great in the
movie so I'm very proud of him so he is
a nepo kitty but he's a good
cat he's called chip and he can't be
here wish he was here actually but he
can't uh Henry I have an individual
question for you you have done a lot of
incredible action set pieces in your
career what do you still think of as
like the hardest thing you've done and
what was it like uh working on this film
in comparison to the other action set
pieces you've done uh the the hardest
action set piece or sequence I've done
uh is easily the helicopter scene in
Mission imp possible that was a crazy I
mean Tom was doing all the real work he
was flying the helicopter um I was just
hanging out the back of the other one
but it was I that sounds like worki
Henry I mean it it was it was just cold
that was the problem and and actually on
on The Bravery piece to begin with
because you have a little half harness
on um with a with a a length of cable
about that long and initially you are
terrified of sitting on the edge of an
open helicopter in the mountains but by
take two you are leaning all the way out
full trust and I mean it's probably not
a good idea but I'm I'm here now so I
think it's okay um but it's amazing how
you stop being scared as soon as you end
up trusting that harness um in compar to
working with with Matthew in these
action set pieces but as you said they
are absolutely enormous and Innovative
set pieces every time and that keeps it
interesting for me because once you
worked with Tom Cruz you think how how
can things get better and bigger than
here and
Matthew does and he makes things
different and new working with Sam in
rehearsals and trying to fall into syn
with each other other and then working
out where cameras are going to be and
you can't cheat in those scenes you
can't be moving the camera around to to
hide a punch the camera man can't save
you so you have to be particularly
precise and moving like someone else
while keeping your character individual
and so working with Matthew in this has
been a has been a new experience for
me Bryce I have a question for you um
you are slowly emerging as someone I
can't let me just say it like this I
can't wait to watch your first feature
film and
[Applause]
right and so I'm I'm just curious uh was
it half he means as a director just to
be clear she has done feature films no
no as a director I'm so I'm so sorry I
didn't say director oh I'm so sorry yeah
I was like yeah she's done this before a
few times my bad so uh what I'm curious
about was half the reason you took this
role so you could watch Matthew on set
and maybe borrow a few things 100% or
know what not to do yeah no I mean
honestly it's it's um my my dad is a
filmmaker and something that
he fantastic filmmaker really he's
awesome um but uh something that that he
really sort of laments is that he he
loved as as he was a young person and
and acting um full-time how he would get
the chance to learn from directors learn
from other actors and and see just
different ways in which stories are told
cinematically and um and so for me like
I like I always feel from the very
beginning I've always felt like a spy on
a set like I I pick things based on the
director um and I want to infiltrate and
I want to observe and absorb as much as
possible and um and just you know
working with Matthew it was ABS I mean I
wanted to work with him just full stop
period as an actor you know um but as as
someone who who craves to learn as much
as possible as a filmmaker how he does
Action his partnership with Brad Allen
um the team around him the way in which
he is just absolutely dogged at creating
something that is fresh and original and
fun
entertaining um it's very very very
exciting to get to be a part of that and
to get to see you know how the sausage
is made essentially and Matthew was um
in the same way that he was incredibly
inclusive with Jason fukes as as a
writer you you were very very very open
with me and and and and just you know
exposing me to the process um whether or
not it was a scene kind of having to do
with my character and I'm I'm just so
grateful for that I and you know it was
really awesome Matthew getting to learn
from
you uh this is a question for the cast
actually I I am a huge fan of all four
of your work and I'm curious I love
talking to actors about the way that you
get ready for
I was like sorry we both counted we just
yeah playing with the and I head right
now so I am curious so say
hypothetically you have like a really
big scene on a Monday morning it's
either really emotional really dramatic
you know you need to deliver that
morning how early on are you actually
preparing for a scene like that is it
when you first get the script you're
thinking about it is it the week before
like could you maybe talk a little bit
about your process when you have a scene
that you're really nervous about
if it includes Matthew Bourn it's
probably 20 minutes before given to
learn the monologue which DRS in your
lap that monologue yeah uh Matthew for
the train scene uh originally it was
just Sam doing all that dialogue and
then he went yeah you know what why
don't you do the dialogue as well and so
there I was thinking oh great uh it's my
first day on set and I need to learn a
monologue in 20 minutes and perform it
and in in front of I haven't worked with
but you had to match the Cadence as well
it was a very Highwire act yeah so ma
with Matthew it's 20 minutes Bravo yeah
and from there from here on out I would
now refuse to prepare until 20 minutes
[Laughter]
before Sam what's your process like uh I
I think it's early on I get nervous
thinking about things uh so hopefully
you know the fights won in the training
camp I
suppose I I don't I don't know I mean
there certain you watch a lot of movies
I watch a lot of movies and I work out
with an acting coach and stuff like that
so then hopefully you've got the script
what does an acting
coach teach you now that you know it all
well there is there are schools for
acting You Know M yeah it is a craft you
do train it's
it's you skeptical no I'm not skeptical
I'm just like do you think I'm I'm
trying does anyone teach Muhammad Ali to
box after he's won Angelo dande taught
Muhammad Ali yeah after he won oh after
he won continued to train with Angelo
dunde anyway it's a fair point um we
won't semantics sing lessons I think he
needs to well but that's cool yeah
that's cool could just not yeah no some
people don't go to school some
people anyway this is not a this The
Listener doesn't need to hear this
conversation I know I would hear it like
being back on
set watching them on this went off in
such a direction I did not expect not
even a little so we'll switch to
something else which is Matthew you got
to put the last Beetle song ever in your
movie so talk a little bit about how you
managed to swing that oh yeah um well I
was trying to find a song for for their
their their love song let's call it and
I needed something with uh sadness but
hope and um Charles Martin who produced
the song um I was with him and he said
would you like to hear a new new or an
old new Beetle song I was just couldn't
get my head I thought he was winding me
up and then he played it and we just
slapped it on every scene and it just
fitted and the lyrics you know now and
then and and then we orchestrated it at
the end you hear the orchestra just you
know they I thought it was a beautiful
piece of music at that time and and then
I had to I had the pleasure of meeting
sa and and and the rest of the well the
Beatles And The Beatles kids and and um
it was just an honor I I couldn't
believe I was getting to work on the
last ever Beatles track and and I had to
keep it a secret for a year and a half
which is you know I had it on my iPhone
I wanted to play it to everyone and I
couldn't um so um yeah and I I'm I'm
very lucky very lucky this is a question
for everyone obviously the shoot must
have been a blast challenging every word
you could add to that sentence but when
you think back on the shoot what's like
the day or two that you will always
remember whether it be because things
went terribly wrong or because it was an
amazing
day I don't know I remember running
around in the kitchen with Bryce trying
to get out of breath I remember but I
just want to say I think what's maybe
I'm stating the obvious here but I think
what's so original about Matthew's films
is that he has a mischievous bad boy and
yet he's also a hopeless romantic I
think that's what Mak am I stating the
obvious there that that's what he makes
his films kind of
special wow thank you it's true it's
true don't you think yeah he's so
naughty and he's so romantic yeah those
two things shows in all his films
naughty and romance is a very very very
good sort of Valentine's Day moment um
and a sense of humor yeah actually one
of my memories was poor was poor
Katherine when her your back went and
she was lying on the deck of the of the
um of the ship and we were doing
stamping and all all this stuff and I
was like Katherine you want to leave
she's like no I'm good and you're down
there for hours stayed on the floor
stayed lying down and I was like okay
and nice didn't complain once no
everybody was kind of sad covering you
in a blanket still okay yeah that was
good that was good CU I got to watch the
stunt all the stunt work up close wow
dig yeah the movie is beautifully edited
the fights are beautifully edited but
I'm telling you you could watch those
fights in person and believe they were
killing each other yeah it didn't need
to be edited you know like like so many
movies are going
pow Zam and you don't know you know
nothing connects this is like a
beautiful
choreography yeah at the end do you guys
want to share any memorable moments or
the day or two you'll always
remember I try to
forget no I think uh all joking aside
any day I was working with Sam and
watching him work
and he really is an absolute genius and
just just beautiful to watch
perform feeling is
mutual
brace and Brian is lovely to be with too
yeah Brian is best he's okay ridiculous
I didn't say he was good at you just
saying no he's cool but really really
funny too I think everyone thinks of him
now you know the your honor or uh
breaking bad but I don't if you remember
uh who's what's this the he's so funny
he's just a really funny improviser and
just crazy funny all the time off camera
totally totally off camera brilliant
brilliant um my thing I hope doesn't
come off as like a spoiler and so just
but I'm just G to be I'm just gonna be
honest with you guys um the the whirly
bird first of all I just want to say um
me doing the whirly bird with Sam does
not look like what do ala doing the bird
with Henry H looks like and um and it
was just it was just the most
absurd thing I've ever done in my entire
life it was really fun but you stayed in
the moment and it is the smile I think
what makes the whirly bird work and
trust me it was something that even when
I was shooting it I was like is this
going to make the final cut I'm not sure
but I had to pretend it definitely is
and it would wind the writer up like no
like we even came up with what only the
whirly bird catches the worm and he's
like no you can't say that I said said
yes we can um but um but I think it's
the looks between Bryce and Sam in both
worldly bird moments was was such joy
and commitment in the moment that I
think you two made the wh Bird work
because you made it feel emotionally
real are you going to make the dance a
hit thank you yeah I'll get soon hoping
everyone's going to pick up the
hopefully it's a new Tik Tok
sensation uh so if you enjoyed the movie
tonight there's this thing called social
media and if you are on it please spread
the word without spoiling the film
sincerely all of you thank you for so
much for coming out tonight and a big
thank you to Matthew Katherine Sam Bryce
and
Henry thank you thank you so much
everyone thoughtful questions and thank
you Steve yes well
done